mögliche annäherung im handelskrieg
us-präsident rampe wird die strafzölle
gegen china vorerst doch nicht erhöhen
und spricht von einem teil abkommen mit
peking streit über türkische offensive
in syrien geraten us truppen unter
beschuss deutschland will neue waffen
exporte in die türkei stoppen
tokio wird geisterstadt ein schwerer
wirbelsturm legt die hauptstadt lahm und
verwüstet japans küstenregion
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen zu
den nachrichten am wochenende mit viel
sport präsentiert von norbert lehmann
doch von mir für die weltwirtschaft
dürfte es eine gute nachricht sein wenn
sie hält was sie verspricht die usa und
china sind offenbar dabei ihren
handelskrieg zu beenden
trump spricht bereits wörtlich von einem
liebes fest zwischen amerikanern und
chinesen andere töne als in den letzten
eineinhalb jahren in denen sich die
beiden größten volkswirtschaften der
welt immer weiter hochschaukeln mit
zöllen und gegen zellen ausgelöst
trumps ärger darüber dass china deutlich
mehr in die usa exportiert als umgekehrt
inzwischen belegen beide die meisten
produkte des anderen mit strafzöllen von
rund 25 prozent
ob der neue die das ändern kann erklärt
ines trams zwei tage hatte seine
delegation nochmals mit den amerikanern
verhandelt ankunft des chinesischen vize
premiers am weißen haus
es war die dreizehnte verhandlungsrunde
sie sollte nicht den großen durchbruch
bringen den präsident trump immer
verlangt hatte aber eine mündliche
vereinbarung zu einem teil abkommen
wir haben einen deal erreicht zu
geistigem eigentum und
finanzdienstleistungen
außerdem ist es ein großer deal für
unsere bauern die chinesen wollen
agrargüter im wert von 40 bis 50
milliarden dollar kaufen die chinesen
versprechen den usa mehr sojabohnen und
schweine abzukaufen auch ihren
bankenmarkt zu öffnen und diebstahl
geistigen eigentums schärfer zu
unterbinden
im gegenzug verzichtet trump darauf
schon bestehende zölle auf chinesische
waren wie angedroht in der kommenden
woche zu erhöhen
wir sind uns einig die us chinesischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zu verbessern
das ist gut für china die usa und die
gesamte welt wir machen gute
fortschritte in die richtige richtung
eine absichtserklärung eine waffenpause
im handelskrieg mehr nicht streitpunkte
wie die öffnung des chinesischen marktes
vertagt doch kampf innenpolitisch mit
der ukraine affäre unter druck feiert
die vereinbarung
es geht um den weltfrieden es gab große
zerwürfnisse zwischen unseren china
jetzt haben wir ein liebes fest das ist
eine gute sache
zum abschluss ein brief mit besten
grüßen vom chinesischen präsidenten
schien ihn wird trump mitte november
treffen offen ob diese mündliche
vereinbarung bis dahin tatsächlich
unterschriftsreif sein wird deutschland
will neue waffen exporte in die türkei
einschränken der grund die türkische
militär offensive gegen die kurden
außenminister heiko maas sagte der bild
am sonntag die bundesregierung werde
keine neuen genehmigungen für
rüstungsgüter erteilen die von der
türkei in syrien eingesetzt werden
könnten
2018 hatte deutschland waffen im wert
von mehr als 240 millionen euro an den
nato-partner geliefert ein zwischenfall
an der nordsyrischen grenze sorgt
außerdem für spannungen zwischen der
türkei und den usa
das pentagon wirft der türkei vor sie
habe us truppen geschossen
in der nähe der grenzstadt kubaner die
türkische regierung bestreitet das und
setzt ihre invasion fort in der von ihr
geplanten sogenannten sicherheitszone gc
gegen kurdische milizen vor
die usa fordern das ende der offensive
und machen druck wird berichtet noch
haben sich die us truppen nicht
vollständig aus dem syrischen norden
zurückgezogen in der kurdisch bewohnten
grenzstadt chorbane detonierte in der
nacht eine türkische granate gleich
neben einer us patrouille
verletzt wurde niemand doch washington
warnte ankara umgehend und deutlich man
habe den angriff gestoppt so das
türkische militär und sich mit den
amerikanern ausgetauscht die spannungen
wachsen
erst gestern hatte der us finanzminister
die ausarbeitung umfangreicher
sanktionen gegen die türkei angekündigt
vorerst nur als drogen
das ist sehr scharfe sanktionen wir
hoffen dass wir sie nicht brauchen aber
notfalls werden wir die türkische
wirtschaft lahmlegen
mit hilfe der artillerie sind türkische
truppen und ihre arabischen verbündeten
inzwischen den mehrere ortschaften in
syrien vorgedrungen der generalstab
meldet auch die einnahme der syrischen
grenzstadt rafah allein diese bilder
hier sollen die mit den türken
verbündeten milizen bei der erstürmung
der stadt zeigen die kurdischen kräfte
erklärten jedoch um die stadt werde
weiter gekämpft
zu überprüfen sind die angaben kaum
welche bilder aus dem kriegsgebiet der
türkischen öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden
das wird vom militär überwacht türkische
soldaten auf syrischem boden sind nicht
zu sehen nur diese arabischen
verbündeten polizei und justiz gehen
außerdem mit festnahmen und
hausdurchsuchungen massiv gegen kritiker
der militäroffensive vor
es darf nicht einmal darüber diskutiert
werden ob so eine offensive überhaupt
notwendig ist
denn über alle steht bei kriegseinsätzen
der türkei über das so genannte
nationale interessen in syrien fliehen
unterdessen weiter tausende menschen aus
den kampfgebieten ins landesinnere gegen
die türkische militär offensive in
syrischen kurden gebeten gab es auch
heute wieder demonstrationen in ganz
deutschland wie hier in hamburg gingen
tausende menschen auf die straße die
überwiegend kurdischen demonstranten
forderten ein ende der angriffe
sie verurteilten das vorgehen des
türkischen präsidenten erdogan
die proteste verliefen laut polizei
friedlich
wir schauen nach münchen in den
löwenbräukeller die spd notiert zur
dreiundzwanzigster und letzten
regionalkonferenz abschluss eines
vorstellungs marathon
gesucht wird ein neues führungsduo sechs
bewerber paare sind noch im rennen
kurz vor schluss verabschiedeten sich
die bundestagsabgeordnete hilde mattheis
und wäre die chefökonomen der kirche aus
münchen das wohnen sagt
da waren es nur noch sechs ein bewerber
fazit am ende aus taktischen gründen
zurück wir machen den weg frei um die
erfolgsaussichten einer linken
spitzenkandidatur zu erhöhen
liebe genossinnen und genossen
tatsächlich sind nach der letzten
regionalkonferenz der spd keine
favoriten für den parteivorsitz
erkennbar klar positioniert haben sich
vor allem die kritiker der großen
koalition
wir wollen endlich die schwarze null
beenden weil wir mehr investitionen im
bezahlbaren wohnraum in den klimaschutz
und in den sozialen zusammenhalt unseres
landes brauchen diese letzten zwei jahre
die wie es in der burg noch bleiben
sollte sind den dauerhaften
glaubwürdigkeitsverlust der partei nicht
wehrt er steht für die schwarze null und
für die groko olaf scholz will
sozialdemokratische projekte weiter in
der regierung umsetzen
soziale sicherheit an funktionierender
sozialstaat natascha ein gerechtes
steuersystem und selbstverständlich dazu
gehört auch die vermögenssteuer ist die
grundlage dafür dass die gesellschaft
zusammenhält und ohne
sozialdemokratische partei wird das
niemals gelingt 23 regionalkonferenzen
mit über 20.000 zuhörern was vielleicht
nach selbstbeschäftigung klingt kommt
bei den mitgliedern gut an
der prozess hilft der partei auf jeden
fall weil er die leute aktiviert also
die leute müssen ja aktiviert werden und
das werden sie dadurch es wird ihnen
vermittelt dass das ernst genommen wird
dass man sie hört dass sie ihre fragen
stellen können das problem
es richtet die person die an der spitze
stehen sondern es muss wirklich der neue
kurse umgesetzt und dann habe ich ein
gutes gefühl dass wir die größe wieder
bekommen die die spd hatte jetzt liegt
der ball also bei den mitgliedern ab
montag darf die spd-basis darüber
abstimmen wer die partei künftig führen
soll und wohin in sachsen könnte bald
eine kenia koalition regieren nach cdu
und spd haben jetzt auch die grünen
koalitionsverhandlungen beschlossen in
leipzig stimmten die delegierten mit
großer mehrheit für die aufnahme von
gesprächen
als knackpunkt galt vor allem die
energie und kohlepolitik ein kenia
bündnis aus cdu grünen und spd gibt es
bisher nur in sachsen anhalt nach dem
terroranschlag von halle hat bayerns
ministerpräsident
der afg heuchelei vorgeworfen die afg
sei nicht auf dem weg eine bessere und
ehrlichere cdu zu werden sie sei auf dem
weg die ware npd zu sein sagte der csu
chef beim deutschlandtag der jungen
union in saarbrücken afd vorstand
wollten wies die kritik entschieden
zurück beim schutz der synagoge in halle
habe es ein fundamentales staatsversagen
gegeben keime in der milch und in der
wurst die jüngsten fälle lassen
aufhorchen der bundesverband der
lebensmittelkontrolleure fordert nun
deutlich mehr personal
im vergangenen jahr seien nur knapp 42
prozent aller registrierten betriebe
überwacht worden
im skandal um die kein verseuchte wurst
des produzenten bilke aus nordhessen ist
nun klar
die firma belieferte bundesweit
supermärkte und kantinen immer mehr
details kommen ans licht susanna sein
team aber dort der weißen flaum auf der
salami isst schimmel genauso wie der auf
dem leberkäse diese fotos hat ein
ehemaliger mitarbeiter von wilcke
gemacht und sie haben auch
gewerkschafter andreas kampmann zerstört
er wehrt sich gegen die behauptung des
landkreises die mitarbeiter hätten sich
nie beschwert
wo der geschäftsleitung gesagt auch über
die abteilungsleiter ebene dass es hier
mängel gegeben hat
sie wurden einfach vom tisch gewischt so
nach dem motto macht du deine arbeit das
andere überlasse uns die wurstfabrik
wurde vor zehn tagen geschlossen
der grund zu hohe listerien werte
listerien sind keime die für
immungeschwächte menschen
lebensgefährlich werden können gab es
schwachstellen bei den kontrollen fest
steht ende august wurde der weg betrieb
überprüft dabei wurden nicht zum ersten
mal massive hygienemängel festgestellt
kurz darauf stellte das landratsamt nach
einer weiteren kontrolle ein positives
zeugnis aus einen monat vor der
endgültigen schließung der fall zeigt
dass es eine viel zu große nähe gibt
zwischen denjenigen die einerseits
verantwortlich sind für die
gewerbesteuer die einzutreiben und
gleichzeitig dann aber auch die betriebe
in der region überwachen sollen
das darf nicht so weitergehen auch die
hessische verbraucherschutzministerin
betont dass sie bisher keine
möglichkeiten habe betriebe zu
kontrollieren oder zu schließen
das ist nicht unsere aufgabe das liegt
allein in der kompetenz der
kreisveterinäre ich möchte gerne dass
wir konsequenzen aus diesem fall ziehen
und das heißt nicht nur umstrukturierung
sondern nach ansicht von foodwatch auch
mehr kontrolleure damit sich ein fall
wie wilke nicht wiederholt polen wählt
morgen ein neues parlament mehr als 30
millionen menschen dürfen ihre stimme
abgeben
als favorit geht die regierenden
nationalkonservativen pis unter
parteichef kaczynski ins rennen
ihr spitzenkandidat ist matthäus
nowitzki der aktuelle ministerpräsident
der name peace steht für recht und
gerechtigkeit bei vielen wählern punkte
die partei mit ihrer sozialpolitik
andere gingen gegen ihre homophobe
rhetorik auf die straße vom wahlkampf
endspurt berichtet natalie steger die
rollenaufteilung ist klar peace
spitzenkandidat ist ministerpräsident
mohammed der einpeitscher peace
übervater kaczynski er wettert bis
zuletzt gegen mehr rechte für lesben
schwule und transgender unsere gegner
träumen von einer großen moralischen
revolution vom zerbrechen der familie
sogar von der auflösung der
geschlechtsidentität von frauen und
männern ein wahlspot apps die
versprechen mehr geld für familien
rentner höherer mindestlohn stolzes
polen verlockend nicht nur für die
traditionellen wähler der pis sie liegt
laut umfragen bei mindestens 41 prozent
gegen den populistischen kurs tut sich
die opposition schwer die größte
oppositionsbewegung die bürgerkoalition
liegt für etwa 22
sie will die umstrittene justizreform
kassieren
die polen werden ein besseres polen
wählen und nicht eine partei die die
demokratie in unserem land zerstört
die sozialdemokraten liegen bei etwa 13
prozent gemeinsam mit den liberalen
hoffen sie die absolute mehrheit der pis
zu knacken
die umfragen fallen dazu sehr
unterschiedlich es ist eine
richtungswahl für polen denn wenn die
pis ihre absolute mehrheit verteidigt
dann geht der umbau des landes der
justiz der medien weiter
das ist das erklärte ziel der pis
konflikte mit brüssel dürften dann zu
nehmen
entscheidend könnte sein ob kleinere
parteien ins parlament einziehen denn
dann wäre die erneute absolute mehrheit
der pis fraglich starkregen und
springfluten in japan kämpfen die
menschen mit dem super taifun megi bis
den vermutlich stärksten seit 60 jahren
am abend ist der wirbelsturm auf der
halbinsel auf land getroffen und zog mit
einer windgeschwindigkeit von 200
kilometer pro stunde weiter richtung
tokio mindestens zwei menschen kamen
bislang ums leben millionen sollen sich
in sicherheit bringen
über die folgen des super taifuns
berichtet ulf röller
normalerweise pulsiert unter der
leuchtreklame das leben aber durch
tokios häuserschluchten jetzt der regen
die millionenmetropole eine geisterstadt
wegen taifun hg dies haben die behörden
mehr als sieben millionen menschen
aufgefordert zu hause zu bleiben nur
wenige trauen sich raus ich habe angst
und ich hoffe mein haus wird nicht
zerstört
tokios nachbarprovinz chiba hat der
taifun schon verwüstet massive
stromausfälle
abgedeckte dächer überschwemmungen zwei
spiele der rugby weltmeisterschaft in
japan fielen aus aber nicht das training
für die harten jungs auch das formel 1
rennen in suzuka vom taifun betroffen
es war völlig richtig hier in suzuka im
großraum nagoya die formel 1
qualifikation auf morgen zu verlegen die
auswirkungen aber des taifuns stellen
sich hier weit weniger dramatisch da als
befürchtet
auch tokyo hofft glimpflich
davonzukommen in diesen stunden wütete
taifun hgb es durch die menschenleeren
straßen
tja und nutzer die ihr norbert und und
er hat super star simon bald aus den usa
mit dem sieg im sprung finale
die 23 wm medaille in ihrer karriere gut
und hat damit die 23 jahre alte
bestmarke des weißrussen cervo
eingestellt unmittelbar nach der landung
weiß simon bolz das ist ihre nächste
goldmedaille ein breites grinsen nach
der zweieinhalbfachen schraube perfekt
ausgeführt und gestanden 15 399 punkte
die konkurrenz wieder einmal chancenlos
gegen die us amerikanerin
enttäuschend hingegen der auftritt von
elisabeth seitz am stufenbarren
der schwierigkeitsgrad ihrer übung hoch
entsprechend wichtig das timing bei den
übergängen dass der 25 jährigen hier
misslingt sie verpasst eine medaille an
ihrem paradegerät gold geht in dieser
disziplin an die favoritin nina der wahl
aus belgien nach dem unentschieden gegen
argentinien peilt bundestrainer löw
morgen gegen estland einen deutlichen
sieg an der gegner klarer außenseiter
und das deutsche team personell gestärkt
ein frischer ostwind und regenwolken
empfangen die reisegruppe in tallinn der
hauptstadt estlands in der nur 12.000
zuschauer fassenden arena fordert volle
konzentration gegen den noch sieglosen
tabellenletzten ist natürlich kein
selbstläufer weil war muss gegen solche
mannschaften wie zuletzt auch sehr sehr
gute ergebnisse erzielt haben natürlich
auch erstmal den chancen herausarbeiten
und daher erwarte ich dass die
mannschaft und das spürt man eigentlich
auch im training oder in gesprächen das
spiel morgen seriös angeht
ilkay gündogan der seine
muskelverletzung überstanden hat wird in
die startelf rücken
internationale fußball auch im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast almuth
schult die torhüterin der deutschen
nationalmannschaft alexanders wäre steht
im finale des atp masters in shanghai er
bezwang den italiener matteo bettini und
trifft im endspiel auf den russen einige
matches starke form
ratlose alexander zverev macht mit
seinem souveränen spiel gegen matteo
barry teenie einmal mehr klar dass er am
ende der saison wieder unter die besten
acht der welt gehören will um im
november in london seinen wm titel zu
verteidigen in shanghai jedenfalls
stimmt die form mit seinem elften ass
beendet wäre das match gegen den
italiener nach nur 67 minuten 6 3 und 6
zu 4
also was von mir zum wetter morgen gibt
es etwas regen im nordwesten im südosten
wird es sehr warm und sonnig mehr gleich
von christa schepp das heute journal mit
claus kleber um 22 uhr 45 und wir sind
morgen wieder da punkt 19 uhr
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit und noch
einen vergnügten samstagabend
[Musik]